boa tarde todo mundo aqui já foi criança
e aposto que todo mundo tem boas
lembranças da infância
pra mim uma das melhores provas que o
caminho o dia inteiro com meu pai para
tentar chegar nesse lugar mas longe de
ser a única
quem aqui já brincou na rua quase todo
mundo né
eu também já brinquei na rua e essa é
uma das minhas boas lembranças mas uma
coisa é a nostalgia de um tempo que já
passou e outra ea gente se lembrar que é
possível transformar essa saudade um
sonho e também uma realidade
essa é a onde eu brincava
eu passava uma parte das minhas férias
na casa da minha avó é bem fácil
imaginar como era o meu dia a dia ele né
pegar pretinha e praia pegar a bicicleta
e na esquina comprar picolé e na casa
das amigas brincam na rua festinhas
olimpíadas tinha a serenata no meu
aniversário
hoje essa rua tá um pouquinho diferente
tá eu sei que essa foto não é super
chocante é só uma bola normal e isso é o
mais grave
esse é um modelo de rua que a gente
conhece mas existem tantos outros
diferentes porque se escolheu um caos
mas não poderiam deixar os filhos
brincando na rua
não foi falta de planejamento foi o
modelo que se escolheu para a rua a
crescer assim a rua da minha infância
por mais simples que fosse tinha
qualidades que se perderam
eu não tenho dúvidas de qual delas
proporcionam um ambiente mais agradável
para brincar na rua mas também para os
adultos conhecerem os vizinhos fazem
amizades um viver e afinal o que é mais
importante do que isso é o que deveria
ser considerado na hora de se pensar o
futuro da cidade
mas a gente vai crescendo e vai perdendo
interesse em algumas atividades e nem se
dá conta de que o lugar onde a gente
vive
bem parece que é um processo normal de
crescimento mais não é normal que a
cidade simplesmente cresça e deixe de
lado aspectos tão fundamentais tão
simples mas tão importantes como aqueles
que deixaram uma rua na minha memória
a rua da minha avó foi um exemplo que a
cidade toda de modo geral não oferece
mais espaços de convívio e de encontro
ea no espaço público onde a gente
encontra e aprendi a lidar com as
diferenças
eu passava uma parte das férias na casa
da minha avó
a outra parte minha família viajava de
trailer pelo brasil e américa do sul
existem várias formas de viajar ea minha
mãe gostava de conversar com as pessoas
pelo caminho houve o jeito de da
informação
ela sempre queria saber quais eram os
orgulhos do lugar e as lendas d'ale
sempre tinha alguém que nos pegava como
braço e levava para assistir uma
apresentação de terno de reis
o outro bem tradicional quando a gente
viajar
a última coisa que passava na nossa
cabeça ir aí naquela grande loja de
departamentos que existe igualzinho a
qualquer lugar ou almoçar numa rede de
restaurantes que o sabor da comida ou
mesmo no mundo inteiro a gente não
viajava para levar nossa aldeia junto a
ideia era anda pela rua ouvir os sons
das fachadas bonitas as visitas bonitas
esses prazeres simples e na feirinha de
artesanato no comércio tradicional
comida típica
não digo só os pratos típicos digo
também aquele docinho e só tem lá a
gente viajava para vivenciar aquilo que
nós chamamos de cultura perceber por
exemplo que a bahia é muito diferente
daqui
a temperatura cor cheiro sabor
arquitetura música sotaque é nesse
conjunto de pequenas coisas muitas vezes
vistas como secundárias que reside
aquilo que nós podemos chamar de alma do
lugar
é pela alma que os meus pais escolher os
nossos destinos e pela alma que as
cidades deveriam se desenvolver com
personalidade própria
foi o que aconteceu ao redor nos cidades
como paris lisboa veneza cuidam de
mobilidade saúde e segurança tanto
quanto dos elementos da mística delas
porque isso é valioso e o que seria a
alma da minha cidade vou pensar um
pouquinho nisso eu sentia necessidade de
sair captar esses elementos e eu vou
passar uma seqüência de fotos com alguns
registros
cada lugar tem no seu conjunto de
elementos simbólicos e com que a minha
cidade deveria se preocupar para se
desenvolver com o corpo e alma e ser uma
cidade do futuro com personalidade
própria
primeiro as pessoas precisam querer que
o desenvolvimento siga um caminho
diferente que tenha valores como
convívio a uma da cidade lazer amigos
passeios encontros
a gente precisa trazer essas variáveis
para a pauta de discussão
nós precisamos perceber que isso é
importante e que a cidade contribui para
a gente ser mais feliz
não é surpreendente que um tema que
afeta tanto a vida de tanta gente não
seja seriamente debatido pelas pessoas
foi nesse contexto que eu e meu namorado
walter daguerre criamos um grupo online
de discussão sobre a temática urbana
a mudança de olhar é o primeiro passo é
uma grande evolução
a idéia do grupo é a cultura urbana em
termos desenvolvido pelo arquiteto jaime
lerner que acredita que assim como na
cultura pequenas agulhadas repercutem no
corpo todo pequenas intervenções
estimulam a cidade inteira dizem que
blumenau deveria ter praia a mais do
metal tem praia assim praia de água doce
com belas paisagens em musina histórica
ea possibilidade de caminhos nas ilhas
fluviais
quem não tem praia é berlim mas por lá
eles conseguem valorizar a presença do
rio no centro com uma piscina flutuante
e cebola não tivesse a sul à croácia se
reergueu economicamente no pós-guerra e
fez uso dos seus parques nacionais com
rotas para bicicletas
será que a gente tem esse tipo de espaço
aqui por perto em tac é só aproveitar o
antigo leito da ferrovia
eu imagino um roteiro de cicloturismo
inter
nacional passando ali e se eu ligasse o
centro com cinco bairros e o parque
nacional por um caminho exclusivo para
pedestres e ciclistas
imagina sair do trabalho e ir pra casa
passeando ou então passeando por parques
lineares onde é mais fresquinho ao longo
dos ribeirões em tantos níveis onde um
casal de idosos pudesse passear de mãos
dadas e as mães com seus carrinhos de
bebê
é assim que eu imaginava blumenau do
futuro
é uma pena que o processo em curso vai
numa linha um pouquinho diferente e que
tal se nelinha para a gente marcar sem
contar com os amigos no centro
essas são novas propostas de sonhos para
a cidade
será que isso é pura utopia é coisa de
sonhadores sem os pés no chão
eu acho que a gente precisa evoluir nos
sonhos enxergar os problemas por um
outro lado vê mais opções de soluções e
pensar se elas equilíbrio do corpo e
alma como essas existem infinitas
possibilidades para todas as idades e
nós fizemos - de propostas pra mim
grande parte delas inspiradas em modelos
bem sucedidos que já funcionam em outros
lugares que eu um membro do grupo
conheceram pessoalmente ou pela internet
o conceito é acupuntura urbana no
sentido de provocar as pessoas a
conhecerem a própria cidade e a
projetarem a própria cidade como um
modelo que pode ser reproduzido em
curitiba florianópolis blumenau outras
tantas
é claro que projetos planejamentos
estratégicos estudos aprofundados eu
indispensáveis eu não estou falando aqui
de certezas e soluções prontas
eu digo trazer mais idéias e fazer
pequenas ações na direção de uma cidade
humanizada
o mais legal da cultura é que é simples
e que engaje as pessoas no processo
cada um pode contribuir com aquilo que
sá
e gosta e quando a gente faz o que gosta
e compartilhem informação e sente que é
útil
mesmo que seja só um pouquinho parece
que as peças de um quebra-cabeça se
encaixa
eu busquei as minhas memórias de
infância e é mais íntima delas era umas
caminhadas ecológicas que fazer com o
meu pai muito mais do que conhecer a
natureza eram dias inteiros com a
família e os amigos em que a gente
atribuir valor para essa coisa
maravilhosa que a região onde a gente
mora em acupuntura urbana pura é
conhecer entender e fazer o uso da
própria cidade
além disso é aproveitar a vida e aí que
parece que tudo se encaixa
logo que me formei
eu trabalhei com o arquiteto ele era
amigo do meu pai foi ele quem fez o
restauro original deste ato que a gente
está hoje um diego olhou pra mim e disse
sabe aquela frase de lindolf bell menor
que o meu sonho não pode ser então ela é
linda
eu gostaria de complementar essa frase
com a vida é um sonho o sonho é uma
realidade sabe as pessoas têm seus
sonhos fazem de tudo planeja um passo a
passo para chegar lá e se esquecem de
viver vai viver a vida vai aproveitar a
vida menina vai viver
pensei que não sou eu falando isso uma
menina com toda a vida pela frente é um
senhor
experiente e renomado não muito antes de
falecer com toda a vida para trás
cada um tem a sua maneira de aproveitar
a vida
eu vou passar uma seqüência de fotos com
a minha maneira de me conectar com sonho
que é a vida através do uso dos espaços
que existem aqui pela minha redondeza
é tudo pertinho é a acupuntura é
aproveitar a vida é repensar a cidade é
dar valor àquilo que
em valor a esses lugares são fantásticos
e deveriam ser um fio quando todo o
planejamento do futuro de toda a região
esse é o vá ele nos encontrou numa
caminhada e daí virou nosso amigo um
companheiro de aventuras é o guapo quem
vai mostrar que não é preciso ir longe
para descobrir lugares extraordinários
vai lavar
camarada de onde pensa febre
nossa alegria breve bull enquanto nos
deixou o camarada viva vida mas
não deixe que ela escuta é quem critica
o sim mas
a caixa d'água guardar água e energia
não caminhou
a alegria não faça brothers da luta pra
tua maneira não perca as estribeiras
saiba tudo
o leão e essa brilhando mais forte em
grande parte à noite
o peixe de manhã
não é preciso ir longe para descobrir
lugares extraordinários
as pessoas dão desculpas para não
viverem os seus sonhos
dizem que a culpa é do governo é do
dinheiro também pode ser mas chega de
terceirizar responsabilidades
tá eu sei que tem pessoas que têm
valores muito distintos e no caribe a
pensar opinião e atitude mas tô aí que
brincava na rua porque gosta de ver o
pôr-do-sol e levar o filho para passear
no parque
faz alguma coisa por ti e também pela
sua cidade cidade significa lugar de
cidadãos e como anda a nossa cidadania
o gregory tem um plano de arborização de
mais de mil adultos
ele ainda faz calçadões aos sábados
o léo jeovânio fábio se juntaram a
organizar uma feirinha aos domingos onde
é que não tinha nada na cidade
o clóvis articulou artistas montam uma
espécie de viradão cultural boas dedicou
à vida o cicloativista e convidava todo
mundo pra ver condominial é linda sobre
duas rodas acupuntura as pequenas ações
de grão em grão a galinha enche o papo e
quem faz acontecer são as pessoas
acontecendo na minha cidade deve
acontecer na tua também encontra alguma
coisa que gosta de fazer apóiam um
desses malucos que querem fazer alguma
coisa uma cidade melhor é possível a
gente precisa usar de maneira diferente
e pensar nela com mais afeto
qual é o teu sonho para a cidade vamos
sair juntos